and then Saturday the valley celebrating
with the golden knights at a parade in
the evening on the Las Vegas Strip 100
expected to pack Red Door all
joining us now with the preparations 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthey
hey guys yes the second major Pro Sports
parade here on the Las Vegas Strip is
happening this Saturday it will start
right here at Flamingo heads all the way
down to Tropicana down this stretch here
now if you were here for New Year's Eve
or even for the aces parade back in
September law enforcement shares with us
the restrictions and crowds may look
very similar
it's not the strips first cavalcade
thousands stood shoulder to shoulder for
hours after the aces WNBA Championship
win nine months ago
and according to Metro Police more than
400 000 did too for the strips New
Year's Eve fireworks
foreign
outside T-Mobile Arena Tuesday just a
glimpse of the Crouch to come Saturday
Las Vegas itself is very used to
celebrations Jonathan Alvarez CEO of the
security company protective Force
International says resources to mitigate
threats along the Route are already in
place the parade starts from the
flamingo intersection at 7 before the
mile track down towards Tropicana then a
rally on Toshiba Plaza at nine three to
four hours of activity and crowds where
Alvarez says his officers will be
patrolling whether it will be canine
sweeps additional resources of Manpower
and working everyone together law
enforcement private sector
early as traffic plagues the area a
Clark County representative confirms as
the parade travels southbound fans can
watch from the sidewalk or streets along
barriers but as for parking and much
else a golden knights representative
says they will solidify this information
on Friday the law enforcement here
Casino partners and outside security
Partners all work together to ensure
everyone has a safe environment to
celebrate in
County and Metro Police both were
seemingly unclear about the parking
situation for this event though the
Regional Transportation Commission they
confirmed to us they will be offering
Express services from all six of their
Express locations game day Express
locations throughout the valley
reporting live on the Las Vegas Strip
Brian Matthew 8 News Now